you that was a cop right did you have a
good relationship with them no my dad
had two emotions angry and not angry yet
and yeah he was he was what they called
my dad I come from a long line of
Alcoholics my dad wasn't a drinker he he
was with uh he's what they call a dry
drunk right so he still had all the
anger and rage of an alcoholic but we
never got to enjoy any of the fun drunk
times
so uh
um you know my dad worked two and three
jobs his whole life he put us to
Catholic school and so he he was a good
father in lots of ways you know but you
know he's just emotionally like most men
you know he wasn't available and he
wasn't really approving you know very
much I remember the first time he saw me
do stand up was in uh Las Vegas and I
was at the MGM Grand and it was a
beautiful room and I had a great show
and afterwards I go dead when they went
my parents weren't saying anything and
we're standing outside the bathroom
waiting for my little sister to get out
of the bathroom my parents were saying
anything and I go mom what'd you think
of the show she goes what did you think
I go I thought it went good she goes
then it went good let's eat that's
hilarious and I was like holy so
then later that night later that night I
say to my dad I go Dad what did you
think of the show he goes the language
you don't even use it right and I was
just Jesus Christ I didn't know I was
just like so that was yeah so it was
crushing in a way right and then I had
to forbid my parents from coming to my
school that's right it's the last time
you ever come yeah but was that was that
do was your comedy due to the life that
was very intense was it your way of
coping with stuff or no you were just
funny always I think it was yeah I was
the youngest I come from 12 kids right
so my
it's a long story but I was the youngest
boy and then when I was in school my mom
got lonely
because all her kids are at school all
day so she went and adopted two more
kids I'm not kidding hold on did you say
12 kids so we had 10 kids and my mom
adopted two more
Baker's Dozen family going on over there
it worked out I had one older brother I
was wow I wasn't thrilled that she
adopted someone older than me I could
kick my ass and because I had enough of
that already right I was there you were
the youngest yeah but then I got a
little sister Rod which she adopted a
little sister so that was fun I guess to
have a little sister you had to beat her
up a little bit yeah a little bit yeah
we're gonna go Jim and then she has
triplets which are great so anyways is
um so growing up I did talk about in my
stand-up I know my parents didn't like
because I talked about getting hit as a
kid right and they don't like that they
didn't like they didn't like her hair in
that but I did we my parents uh they saw
hit us for discipline which and now as a
grown-up it's always what would I say in
my actors it's always horrible when
someone hits their kid in front of me I
never know when you're supposed to step
in you know yeah one time I was in the
airline terminal this lady's hitting her
kid he's like five years old she's
wailing on him and finally go hey why
don't you cut it out you're creeping
everybody out and she goes no you got to
hit him make some good people oh wow and
I was like wow how many punches would it
take to make you a decent
turns out 80. yeah exactly yeah
teacher she's really nice now by the way
just just because we've been talking
about this a lot have you ever seen a
movie The Judge because the father son
you've never seen the movie the judge
you guys are killing me what is this
if you like that scene from the movie
you were talking about you're gonna love
the joke yeah so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]